hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey
we got mics out for the Joker 2019 movie
directed by todd phillips starring
joaquin phoenix famous for his portrayal
of the bad guy in gladiator some other
things this is one of those reviews are
nervous about I thought I might be a
little bit more on the conflicted side
of how do I really feel any time to
process this but honestly I really know
how I feel about this movie and I want
to make sure I say everything correct I
want to make sure I get all my points I
crossed and it's such a thick complex
experience of sorts having a hard time
processing all my vocabulary of how I
wanted to come across I'll tell you guys
this much - I loved it I was not halfway
through this movie I looked to my
girlfriend Olivia I was like how you
feeling about this movie so far I love
this an interesting film to watch
because it's a challenging experience
you could hear all kinds of different
reactions word or certain audience
members who were laughing really hard at
some stuff moments where when they were
laughing I was kind of pissed they were
laughing because I clearly felt very
different towards certain scenes and
that's kind of the power in this movie I
think because of that level but John
really quickly would you think overall
yeah I mean I'm kind of in the shoe zyou
expected to be in which is I don't know
exactly where my emotional you know
experience what this movie is going to
settle but I do think that there is a
whole lot of really quality work worth
appreciating it is very striking and it
is very compelling in a very strange
kind of way uncomfortable in a unique
way as well so I think it definitely
succeeds at being a unique and singular
experience for sure I feel like I
prepped myself perfectly for this movie
when this movie was announced they're
talking about Scorsese possibly
producing this film and it being in the
vein of something like taxi driver Todd
Phillips was pretty vocal about how it
borrows inspiration from taxi driver and
king of comedy rather than doing too
much a comic book research because I
heard that they didn't borrow anything
from any comics wouldn't adapting and
this movement so many jokers
when I was getting in the mood to watch
this I'm today's Thursday of filming
this and a Monday I watched taxi driver
and I hadn't seen it since the one time
when I was a kid and a lot easier to
appreciate in your late 2014
appropriately adult reuses and then I
also rewatch King of Comedy which I
watched right around the same time I can
definitely see the inspirations
especially with this movie being set in
the 80s and sort of the world that you
know this takes place in Gotham but if
it feels like New York from the 80s a
rather cynical nihilistic world we kind
of like alley-ooped the way to summarize
this movie when we're out of the theater
it is his own thing it wasn't like I was
rewatching taxi driver at King of Comedy
even though there are scenes where I'm
like oh that's directly from King of
Comedy like there are there are certain
choices that completely reminding me of
both of those movies it's like what if
Rupert Pupkin became Travis Bickle if
you just throw in the Joker if you throw
in like a comic book world yeah if taxi
driver and King of Comedy took place in
a comic book world I think it is
important to kind of acknowledge taxi
driver ankang a comedy because it's very
evident that there were approaches to
this over inspired by it and with those
movies you got robbed an airplane two
very different types of psychopathic
characters so you could tell are very
mentally ill and mentally unstable but
the movies don't ever go out of their
way to comment on mental illness per se
they don't they're not very direct about
it whereas this movie is this guy goes
to therapy or at least checks in with a
psychologist there's very specific
sometimes on the nose things well I
appreciated it when I was on the nose
action I felt it was good to be a little
bit expositional about certain things it
is very much talking about mental
illness and that's not to say cuz I know
there's controversy around this movie
when we were talking about this on the
car ride back I was saying how this
movie is really like Arthur Fleck
portrait of a killer yeah you know I
don't think this movie necessarily has a
stance as much as it is just doing a
portrait of who this guy is the world he
lives in and yes because of the world he
lives in there comes with some
commentary about the way government
treats proper funding or treating those
with mental health people yeah
helps a city to thrive you know versus
just thinking of financial interests and
what exactly and as someone who I mean
I'm pretty vocal about it I've been in
therapy for I've lost count at this
point and you know I've was diagnosed
many years ago PTSD ADHD type-2 bipolar
and I've been surrounded by people who
have really serious mental health
struggles none to this you know and then
they hear about the kind of crimes that
are happening in the world today so I
can't get why there's controversy
surrounding this movie I think it's only
because it's a big blockbuster or at
least it's marketed like a block big
blockbuster it has the IP of Joker in it
that's why there's controversy around it
one of the places I'm kind of conflicted
on this movie because I think it does do
a nice job of humanizing and putting
this in a world that yet is not as broad
and comic-book II with its motivations
but it is sort of going okay we have
this neglect and what happens to a
person that grows up in that and what
happens to a person with that nurture
system no support and everything is the
bare minimum and I've met people who you
know seem to be kind of chronically down
on their luck I think the movie does a
good job of like acknowledging that
stuff I don't think the movie really
discusses it much I think it uses it as
flesh for Arthur's character and a time
and place setting for everything like
here's what's going on and Gotham right
now which is I think smarter and better
for the movie personally I can see it I
guess yeah just because the movie sticks
strictly to character study of Arthur
flex to me just the level I came out of
this with I felt like I got a character
observation more than a complete study
this is fair because like the problem is
that weirdly it's funny because I don't
think the King of Comedy or taxi driver
are detrimental comparisons and I wasn't
really thinking about those movies
during watching this the weird thing is
I was thinking of you were never really
here because that's the movie I kept
going to for like this gets into the
psychosis to a level where I'm affected
by it more than just I'm observing it
and so I think he does a really good job
of acting it out and doing the portrayal
I don't think the writing necessarily
does much exploring of it it just kind
of acknowledges that it's there that's
just kind of what do you want from this
yeah I definitely felt different to it
because because I had
believe connected with the Arthur Floyd
character you've heard everyone say it
even those who don't really like the
movie you've heard them say it that
Joaquin Phoenix is freakin broken in
this movie man I really thought he was
incredible every every single moment I'm
not watching a dude act I've seen so
many interviews of walking in Phoenix
I've seen so many like different
portrayals of characters he's done this
is like a full-on transformation of
sorts and it also arcs in a in a way
that's different then I think how you
might be led because it's hard not
especially watch the trailers knowing
Joker you have certain expectations I'd
expect this movie didn't necessarily arc
and it doesn't really arc in the I don't
want anymore Joaquin Phoenix the word
that comes to mind is literally as
pathos like this guy is someone you
really sympathize for and there's a
little bit you said in the car like
there's a little bit of Arthur and all
of us in a lot of ways there's a certain
degree of very specific mental health
areas and actions he commits and does
and in yadda-yadda-yadda
there were times I weirdly I straight up
like rooted for him but never in the
realm of people in real life and going
this way within the the suspension of
disbelief of the movie even when he was
doing things I was never necessarily
shocked by but I always felt impacted by
I would still understand where he's
coming from well I think that's the
deepest point this movie hits because it
does use some relevant ideas and I think
the most relevant of them is this idea
it's that theme of the Joker that
anybody's one bad day away from snapping
and becoming potentially this person
we've see we see it in culture now with
all these mass shootings and stuff so
like well he's one bad life away yeah
and that's I think that's the true
flashpoint that is the controversy ha ha
ha ha flashpoint they're gonna come in
next flash movie put the Joker in the
next Batman 23 when that flash finally
drops I think that's the linchpin of the
controversy
that's that's yeah the crux Horcruxes
very modern
that's the nucleus Silicon Valley at the
heart of the controversy I think is
something very interesting about the
movie which is that Joaquin Phoenix's
portrayal is horrific and scary at times
but it is also childlike and sad in ways
and yeah you can sympathize with aspects
of his character it's in that broad
stroke the movie because we need to take
better care of these people and part of
the broken financial system is that
people get forgotten pushed around and
with no support with no good friends if
you have the right combination of mental
disorders or troubles you might find
yourself completely isolated and ready
to blow up but I think that's the most
relevant thing this movie touches even
if I wasn't fully connected in terms of
like identifying with the character I
was always fascinated by what was
happening with him and I do credit todd
phillips a lot for how this film was
captured the cinematography in this
movie was so beautiful like we saw it on
an IMAX and I was kind of like it's good
maybe need a watch on IMAX it sounds
like just a character study film and
then I wait shy or like oh it's funny
it's in the 80s and it's the least I've
thought about it because so many things
are back in the eighties right now but
this felt like a movie that could have
kind of fell out of the yeah oh
definitely and then there are things
especially with like fleshing out the
Gotham world that they like a little
subtle touches like oh that thing says
Gotham on it says Gotham PD yeah touches
both on the the depth side and they're
just comic book side and also I think
what everyone's in agreeance on at least
they should be
this is a should I don't care how
subjective opinions music is freakin
phenomenal oh yeah I was walking out of
the theater still hearing the music in
my head blew my mind away very ominous
very fraught haunting I just thought
that the way this whole movie is
composed and I feel like that's a good
word to use for it it's a very composed
film it's like we can all talk about
subject matter controversy in
yada yada which is I think I'm
fascinating it to walk out of this movie
talking about because there's only a few
things that we could say for a spoiler
talk that are like comic book II yes
very few it's so few to the point that
when it happened I kind of wished it
wasn't in the movie which is kind of
weird because I was so into this movie
yeah and I didn't view it as a comic
book movie that when a comic book thing
happened which is very very rare I was
like I couldn't know that yeah the most
comic book thread this movie has is yeah
the one I would have snooze yeah yeah
and it's not even like take it the whole
thing out it's just a couple things you
could have like the only time when I
felt like I was in Todd Phillips got a
studio now let him get a lot of [ __ ]
couple things
after watching tax traffic in comedy I
wasn't like oh but then also like we
grew up on like horror movies and we've
watched films that are like so much more
brutal I think it's because it's
categorized in the blockbuster train and
the end the audience reach this movie
has why these topics are being brought
up with this movie specifically because
of the potential region have like Rob
Zombie comes out with like the most
freaking in-your-face nihilistic
sinister film you could think of that
just frickin mean but Joker yeah makes
sense
IP like we've already covered but the
thing is though like the violence in
this film the best comparison you give
this movie in terms of like other
Joker's without spoiling Jack about the
film's Cesar Romero Cesar he artx into
Ceasar you watch Heath Ledger's Joker
and that's a joker who is a criminal
mastermind and that is not this
portrayal no this portrayal is a dude
with serious psychotic issues honestly
this movie I thought did a really good
job at humanizing this character that I
feel like I'm being kind of insulting by
calling him psychotic but he's not
unleashing it to like the Heath Ledger
Joker or the chair literally watching a
dude with a serious mental disability
that when the
violence occurs it's not a gleeful
maniacal like outburst it hits its pop
yeah it's like you've seen films that
are way more gory than this but when it
happens it feels realistic there's no
Joker kills a dude with a magic pencil
moment you know all of them all the bio
mystique there it's ugly and it hurts
yeah oh there's like spoiler moments I
would definitely like to go over but for
me it's a high recommendation and I
could see audiences means literally half
the crowd strongly applauded after crowd
immediately left it's fun to walk into a
moving really not knowing how you're
going to feel afterwards and I mean yeah
this movie I definitely if you're
interested at all or if you're involved
in the controversy go see what it is
it's a very striking movie it's gonna
take me some time to figure out my
actual thoughts I guess I got the movie
I expected which is kind of the one of
the keys to my weird mood right yeah
sort of like I guess the missing element
for me was it never felt truly chaotic
or unexpected I never really wasn't able
to predict where it was gonna go I think
that is a truly a central part of a
Joker but other than that I think it is
a really interesting achievement for
superhero cinema and I think it's a
well-made film overall alright guys well
did you see Joker what did you think
about it comment below you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell keep a lookout for a
spoiler talk see you guys